i demek is a mobile game developer and
publisher we are based in room 10 in
Manchester and we make free-to-play
mobile games our hip product is a game
called God clashed on the top 30 grating
mobile games on Google Play and the
number two sports game on Google Play
side Emmet was founded by myself and
Alex Rigby
alex is a long-standing friend of mine
and he and I really grew up together
gaming was always something that we love
to do in fact we actually wrote a
fanzine about to do games at one point
which really shows the depth of our
geekiness
our vision for God basher was to create
something that really was less about
golf and more about a competitive fun to
play gaming you could simply play in
three or four minutes downing the queue
or the bus stop or at home after testing
many ideas we found that golf in its
purest sense simply getting a ball into
a hole was something that really
appealed we wanted the player to be able
to pick up that game and play it one son
one son gaming is something that's very
important to us that's simple easy to
access mechanic that we believe golf
crash really expresses gold clash is
done incredibly well in storage we've
had many millions win stores and we're
now played by over a million players
every single day which makes us very
happy as developers we've been amazed by
the engagement and Google Play we see an
average of four to four minutes a day
committed by our players to the game of
three sessions
we've also seen great monetization the
average revenue per user on Google Play
is the same as on the other platforms
half of our business is now generated by
Google Play over years we've been making
free-to-play games we've learned live
ops are vital to really entertaining
engaging players that play the game over
long periods of time
because developers we need to come up
with ways of surprising players in the
fun content that engages them and as a
result of that they made enguarde to
spend my money tournaments were our
first direction of a light up and game
we knew the users wanted tournament you
feel that they're giving us through the
rating review so we developed a system
run for a week we'd coincide it to run
alongside a real-world golf event for
the players that really do follow God
and it proved a huge success in fact we
saw our revenue double during that week
which really showed how much the players
enjoyed that experience that will now
become a stable part of our lineup
strategy we'll have a regular cadence of
tournaments and we can drive by data we
don't need to get a new release I'm
going to come up with cadence of
coordinates that can play as Moto's so
they don't know when to come back from a
lot of social media around those events
could just click refresh the content in
the game and make it surprising and fun
into the flames I'm really lucky to make
video games for a living
and there are a few people in the world
that can say that they get up in the
morning and go do something love every
day I feel very fortunate to be able to
say that I do that we run a mission to
be one of the biggest mobile game
publishers in the world and that remains
our focus and our passion
you